una curva tiene una ecuación de igual a
tangente de equis y pasa por los puntos
igual a pi 41 y que igual a x coma
tangente de x escribe una ecuación sobre
x que nos dé la pendiente de la secante
que une a p y aquí muy bien entonces
vámonos a la herramienta de dibujo
justamente para poder hacer un dibujo y
vamos a hacer la gráfica de esta función
aquí está el problema y queremos ver la
gráfica de yegua la tangente de x
pintamos el eje
ahí está el eje y
y elegí y ahora pintamos el eje x
ahí está el eje x más o menos está
derecho muy bien entonces lo que nos va
a ser muy útil es recordar que la
tangente de x la tangente de x es el es
igual al seno de x / coseno de x
entonces sabemos que esta función es
periódica y de hecho tiene periodo 2 p
así que me voy a restringir el intervalo
menos pi medios y medios verdad y eso se
va a repetir en todo el eje verdad así
que déjenme déjenme ver qué pasa cuando
x es igual a x es igual a 0
si x es igual a 0 seno de cero es cero y
coseno de cero es 1 entonces esto nos da
0 así que la gráfica pasa por aquí y
está
qué va pasando cuando x tiende tiende a
pi medios
y digo tienden porque no lo podemos
evaluar en pi medios porque ese no de
medios es cero es cero si en efecto es
no perdón seno de mil medios es uno pero
coseno de pi medios es cero entonces
estaríamos dividiendo entre cero pero
esto se va haciendo por el infinito
verdad entonces como dividimos entre
primer entre cero perdón en realidad la
función se va yendo hacia infinito hacia
infinito si nos vamos por la derecha
verdad entonces lo que hace la tangente
de x es irse más o menos así y en menos
y medios pasa exactamente lo mismo pero
hacia abajo verdad más o menos esto hace
algo así
y entonces en menos y medios lo que pasa
es que se va a menos infinito entonces
esta es la gráfica de tangente de equis
y nos dice bueno tómate un punto y
cuartos coma
1 entonces nos vamos a pi cuartos aquí
estamos en pi cuartos y el valor aquí es
1 aquí vale 1 este es nuestro punto p
dice tomate otro punto q x coma tangente
de x eso nos está diciendo que es
cualquier otro punto sobre esta curva
entonces por ejemplo vamos a tomarnos
este de aquí x
vamos para arriba y este va a ser
nuestro punto cu que es x tangente de x
bien es este muy bien ya que tenemos
esto planteado ahora trazamos la recta
secante que une ap ya q entonces ok
vamos a ver si me sale ahí está más o
menos la recta secante
más o menos y ahí está muy bien y nos
pide ahora finalmente escribir una
ecuación sobre x porque está x pues fue
arbitraria que nos dé la pendiente de la
secante que une a esos dos entonces para
calcular la pendiente necesitamos ver
cuánto cambiamos en x y cuánto cambiamos
en g entonces cuánto hubo de cambio en x
pues simplemente es x menos y cuartos
verdad esto es un pi ok y ahora que
tanto cambio hubo en el cambio y fue
igual así digamos aquí estamos en
tangente de x verdad entonces de hecho
aquí es x y aquí es vale 1 entonces el
cambio en yes tangente de x menos 1
entonces finalmente la pendiente se
calcula como el cambio en y entre el
cambio en x que es igual la tangente de
x menos 1 sobre
y cuartos y cuartos mientras sobre x y
cuartos
x menos pi cuartos muy bien y entonces
si nos acordamos de esto y lo ponemos en
él en la página de la cadena academy
debería darnos una respuesta correcta
vamos a acordarnos entonces la respuesta
era
movernos un poco
que se vea
entonces la respuesta
vernos
vamos a darlo entonces están gente de
equis tangente de x menos 1 y eso hay
que dividirlo entre x menos pi entre 4
books es todavía que agruparlos
ahí está entonces ahí tenemos la fórmula
de la pendiente que obtuvimos y vamos a
comprobar la respuesta y fue correcta